thank you
thank you uh good morning everybody
welcome to this meeting of the trafford
covid 90 public engagement
board um i'll start i will start by
wishing everyone a happy new year but it
seems to me that we're very much in the
the same as last year
and probably a bit a little bit further
up the creek without a paddle but there
we go
we are where we are uh and thank you for
you as i say for attending this morning
um the uh number one on the agenda is
attendances
um i i want to welcome this morning
members
uh elected members from scrutiny who
think of georgia's for the first time
you're very welcome and thank you for
your attendance um
i only have notification of one apology
and that is from george devon are there
any other apologies at
all
uh no other apologies received chair
thank you and also welcome shannon who
standing in this
morning for a superintendent caroline
hemingway thanks for attending
uh declarations of interest at number
two on the agenda are there any
declarations of interest from anybody
silence is golden of course there so
we'll move on to the minutes
can i take the minutes from the last
meeting as read by members
thank you does anyone want to wish to
raise any matters of rising from those
minutes that aren't covered in the
agenda
thank you therefore we'll move on to
item four the update on the current
covid 19 situation in trafford elena
over to you thank you
sorry taking a while to one mute um
hello everyone and
um yes the situation isn't isn't where
we would want it to be
just before i start i wanted to
introduce um a new member of the team
uh ellie caddick who's our new comms
officer work
so um she along with our community
engagement team will be really important
um supports to this this board so um
welcome to ellie
um so the situation at the moment in
trafford
is that along with the rest of greater
manchester star rates have been
increasing sharply
um we are seeing a an increasing
proportion of our cases
are the new variant of covid um which as
people will be aware
is more infectious than the previous
version um that was circulating the
for an individual the risks to it remain
the same so it's you're not more likely
to be seriously ill but obviously if
something's more infectious
more people will become ill and more
people will potentially end up
in hospital with it so so the big
concern um
is to try and really get on top of on of
this um
this variant uh and to reduce the rates
in our borough
it's the same exactly the same methods
um and the precautions that you need to
take it's nothing different from
previously but it does mean that people
really do need to be scrupulous
about abiding by the guidelines and the
guidance that's given so maintaining
that social distancing
really limiting the number of social
contacts you have
really at this point i would say over
the over the winter
and i know it's hard but you know
absolutely do not let
anyone from outside your household into
your home
don't visit anyone else um you know do
make sure you go outside you get
plenty of fresh air and exercise but it
is that meet no more than one person
from outside your household
and and make sure you even outdoors keep
that distance
avoid crowded places as much as you
possibly can
so um you know including crowded
supermarkets all sorts of places just
make sure that you're in
as well ventilated the space as you
possibly can be
look after yourselves so we've seen that
we have seen a big increase in our rates
um and uh last monday on the fourth we
had the highest number of cases we've
seen
throughout since february or since
certainly since we were doing the mass
test easier um testing
since may so we had 217 people tested
positive
on the 4th of january so over a thousand
people a week at the moment
are testing positive for covid in
trafford and those cases are spread
throughout the borough
it is it really is everywhere and we're
also seeing a lot of households with
numbers of
a number of people within the household
and i think that again
picks up
and through you i believe we have a
problem with the eleanor's
connection less attention to um to
hygiene and making sure that you don't
spread that
to other people in your family um
over christmas and you'll see in the the
data
we've heard a lot about the impact of
schools and children
on this and it does appear to be that
children
are more infectious than they were
previously in this one but that doesn't
mean they're more infectious than adults
and where we're seeing our big increases
at the moment is in our working age
population
we did see a bit of a drop in the number
of cases in children over the christmas
holidays
when schools were shut but the numbers
of cases in the working age and that
at that time actually increased so
it really is something that we all as
adults need to be taking very very
seriously
and making sure we think about our
behavior and closing the schools
over christmas did not stop our rates
increasing sharply
as i say in that working age group and
the other thing that we have seen
is a lot of cases came through
the very end of december and early into
into the beginning of january
and we suspect that is probably just
people mixing a bit more over christmas
and and you know the sadness of this is
that a lot of this will be probably
people who have absolutely abided by the
rules
but it is so infectious and because it's
um people can be
infectious when they're asymptomatic um
you know probably people
did inadvertently give it to each other
over christmas to their friends and
family and i think that reinforces
at the moment with kovit it is the
people that you are closest to that are
the biggest danger and you're the
biggest danger to them
so absolutely please please take care of
yourselves
and your families um i think
i'll stop there i'll take any questions
thank you uh are there any questions at
all raise your hand i've got councillor
new grosh
thank you very much sorry elena you did
actually cut out just as you were giving
us the rates there
i'm just wondering if if you did have
the uh
the per 100 000 rate and any indication
of where we're at on the percentage of
new variant
um so our current rate is about 445 per
hundred thousand
um we're more or less at the top of the
greater manchester figures at the moment
and we had over a thousand
over a thousand cases this week um in
the la in the week
of the fourth to the 10th um and
we estimate about 50 percent of the
cases of the new variants
once the new variance here it's likely
to become a bigger and bigger proportion
because of course it's more infectious
so it displaces um the the other variant
so that's the situation we're in
we're it's too soon it feels
like we're hoping that we're starting to
see a leveling off of our figures but at
a very very high rate
it's too soon to see say that we're
seeing a drop
we're not seeing a drop but we're not
increasing as fast as we
were and that's the piece of good news i
want to give to people because i think
if
you know that is something that if we're
not increasing as fast as we were
then actually all of us working really
hard on this and absolutely abiding by
that social distance and limiting
contacts respiratory hygiene
washing your hands all of those things
don't go anywhere that you don't have to
go
we will get on top of this it's not out
of control
so please don't think it is it is
absolutely something we can get on top
of
um but we need to work really hard at it
thank you very much i appreciate that
thank you council new gross i
i've got a just an observation to make
here and
it doesn't feel to me that this is like
anything like the lockdown that we had
going back to march some of our schools
have got attendance of nearly up to 50
percent
um there is a lot of movement around the
borough
um we have supermarkets which have
been quite tardy in relation to social
distancing
uh it just does it's just a different
feel about it eleanor to me
uh and i'm wondering about pops further
down the agenda when we get to our uh
engagement board activity about
messaging about how we can
we can start to to around the other to
change that or get the right message
across because i do know that
school where i'm chair of governors have
now sent a letter out to parents from
last night saying look
you know you might be you might say
critical worker but if you can work from
home
we are not going to take your child uh
because
we are full you know and and it's an
issue
uh and the other issue that concerns me
as well is in observation is this talk
of the government extending
uh testing to primary schools um
i just don't fathom that one at all but
there we are
uh just a couple of observations so i
think
i think you are right about the um that
this lockdown doesn't feel the same
i think i think one of our difficulties
is that in the first lockdown a lot of
people were very very frightened
and actually it's very hard for us as
humans to operate when we're really
frightened and it's not good place to be
so
there is that balance between people um
i think as well probably this time we we
aren't noticing quite the difference
because it's not such a sharp contrast
between
all the things we used to do when you
think what we used to do in early march
in early march we were still in the
offices you'd if you went to a meeting
it would you know some of us would be
trying to do sort of an elbow bump
instead of shaking hands but it was you
know we were still
in a very very almost touchy feely place
if you like and we're not there now as a
society so i think a lot of us have
changed our behavior
a lot and we it's almost it's become so
normal
that we're not noticing the differences
that we've made since march so i think
there may be something about
thinking about how we are now compared
to how we were in march is perhaps we've
changed more aspects but we've got used
to them so that
they're now feeling normal to us i do
think um i mean i think in in schools
and helen i'm sure we'll come in but our
schools have been working really hard
throughout and all of our schools were
open all of the christmas
of the autumn term with all of the
children in
and actually our rates now are the
similar to where they were at our worst
point in october
and admittedly this fact that this virus
now is is more infectious so we need to
be more worried
but our schools have managed really
really well throughout they have done
fabulous work so i think that we need to
be
cautious about worrying i think the
schools
will be worried and i absolutely
understand that
but i think most of the behavior change
that we need to be seeing is in about
adults
and about adults making a real you know
we've certainly had some businesses
still
who are encouraging people to come to
work when they don't need to
still some businesses where you know
some of their
social distancing measures methods at
work and their code for security
methods at work and not where they
should be we're seeing a number of
outbreaks in in businesses now
um so i think it is all of us upping our
game
um and really thinking you know i
we absolutely have over the next and
while we're waiting for the vaccine to
take effect
while we're waiting for the weather to
get better so that other diseases and
other illnesses are less prevalent and
our health services under less strain it
really is about all of us putting that
challenge back and thinking
do i need to do this now and what can i
stop doing how can i how can i keep
people safe
i'm uh i'll leave the i'll leave helen
and donna to talk about the
primary school testing um but perhaps
under the testing item
thank you thank you i had any further
questions at all for uh
on this item
i don't see any okay let's move on sorry
for you i think there is a question from
councillor welton
yeah i think he raised his hands
councillor welton
thank you very much um unfortunately now
i have a personal experience of
of the symptoms of kovid and as do my
household and i find it concerning now
you know having gone through that that
um
the you know basically we're asking
people to diagnose themselves based on
these three
three major symptoms before they go for
a test
and but so many of the symptoms you know
relate to the common cold and it can
very much come
come on like a common cold feels to me
like we need to be a lot
simpler in our messaging to people and
say if you have
any symptoms of the common cold whatever
it is a sore throat achy limbs
you know um you know a headache that you
should go for a test
because you know we're getting different
advice some of the apps will tell you to
go for a test if you have any
of those kind of symptoms but you know
on the on
on the major websites it talks about the
high temperature the cough
and the um you know and and the smell of
smell or taste
and you know you can have covid and you
can be having symptoms without having
any of those
you know any of those three they may
well come on later as they did in our
in in our case it seems like it would be
a lot more straightforward you know and
i know this would be diverging from the
the national nhs
guidance if we just said if you have any
symptoms of a common cold
go and get a test it doesn't matter what
they are that would be the best way they
would
give complete clarity to people you know
they would know and they you know and
hopefully they would they would be more
inclined to go
rather than just hanging on and and you
know prevaricating a bit
thank you it is a really difficult one
and especially in children we see quite
a lot of
atypical presentation but um at the
moment the national guidance remains
that um in order to manage the testing
numbers that
it is those three key symptoms of the
cough the
um the uh high temperature and
um the loss of sense of taste or spell
and i agree sometimes you know we do
seek cases in people who haven't had
those symptoms but the majority of
people
still do have those symptoms the
clinical definition remains the same
so it is about that management of um
people going for tests
you know trying to keep the management
of the testing numbers
uh reasonable so that the testing
surfaces don't get overwhelmed because
one of the big things is as well trying
to get quick results to people
so i think i mean our advice is um
if it if you you know you should you
should only really go for a test if you
have the key symptoms but if
if you are worried we would never say
and you have symptoms
that are you know particularly
um a severe cold often does have a
temperature as well
so um and those aches and pains and so
on but but our main advice is
you should go for a test when you have
the symptoms because if you go
too soon you may get a negative result
as well so you might
if you go too soon because you think
you've got you know while you're
incubating it perhaps and you've got
those initial symptoms
if you go then you may get a negative
result then when your symptoms develop
further
you may not go back and you may never
get diagnosed so we would really
encourage people to wait until they have
those key symptoms
because that's when it's most likely
that you will get a positive result from
the test
and that's that's the main thing we
don't want people ending up with the
negative result while they're incubating
it
um and then thinking when they get
further symptoms that they're
they just they had a negative and
therefore they're negative
so it's a it is a really really
difficult one but the the rationale
is if you go when you have those uh
symptoms particularly that high
temperature
that's when it the test is most likely
to be accurate
okay then in which case the message
should be if you have any symptoms of
the common cold
you must isolate basically if you you
know and then go for a test if you if
you
develop any of these particular symptoms
but i don't think that is necessarily
coming across
i would say at the moment um that if you
have um
symptoms of a bad cold and you work in
any face-to-face occupation you should
not be you know you should have a much
normally we're very we always soldier on
don't we and you go to work
this is not the time to do that if you
feel ill
if you've got a cold stay off see how it
goes if you get better
that's fine but if it starts to develop
then at least you won't have infected
anyone else
um so no i agree with you i think at the
moment we should be much much more uh
quick not to not to to be worried
and not not risk infecting other people
and do we have messaging going out to
that you know should our message even be
tailored more to that effect then we've
certainly used that messaging since
february with um uh certainly through
the council and in the nhs we've been
using that messaging very strongly with
staff that we're not expecting to see
people you know we do not want people to
come into work if they're not feeling
well because we do not want to be doing
we don't want a whole department um when
people were in the office
but you know in february and so on we
didn't want a whole load of people
having to self-isolate because somebody
had decided to come into work
when they were not well so yes we've
been we've been sending
that messaging and we've been saying
that to businesses as well
yeah do you think that should be going
out more to the general the general
public i mean you know they're just
talking
in in our case that we've
probably picked up in the shops before
christmas you know that i mean
there was no other interaction so
i mean i think it seems like that
message needs to go wider not just
not just a face-to-face you know people
who might be in a face-to-face
occupation but that just needs to be a
message that goes out wide to the public
i think we can certainly do that and
we'll pick that up with um
i'm sure ellie's taking notes of things
that we should be communicating better
and absolutely i'm very happy for those
messages to go out
uh thank you councillor welton um
no further questions i don't see any
i've looked at the chat group
no hands up shall we therefore move on
to the ten point planet can i
first of all invite donna to address his
own mass testing
donna thank you chair um i think um
we're going to change the title from
mass testing now to targeted testing
um the testing regimes and changes
happen all the time don't they because
of the tears that we're in and
because of the different um challenges
and demands on our colleagues
in the nhs so um i think our focus
is on targeted testing um i'm pleased to
let the board know that we have now set
up our um
asymptomatic testing site for
key staff members at trumpet town hall
um that went live chair on monday with
the
huge support from all our colleagues in
the council
whether that was the states whether that
was hr um whether that was our
colleagues in amy
and we managed to get the site up and
running um within a week
which is really good um we have got
a military team there who are helping us
to
run the site so the military team are
doing all the testing
it is only for key staff who we are
inviting at this stage
we're only on day three so we're just
limiting the numbers
to asymptomatic key staff
and our definition is um those staff
um council healthcare staff
housing staff our homeless team our
domestic abuse team
and hopefully we'll will be inviting
primary school staff
themselves um as from tomorrow um
to uh participate in that testing
program
uh we are asking staff to attend twice a
week
um which is quite um an ask for them
because as you know the lateral flow
tests um
whilst um effective in diagnosing um
very infectious people it's best to
repeat it twice a week
to uh to make sure that happens
um we are um at the moment
uh where we had uh 50 on monday which is
our first day which was great
and yesterday we had 85 stuff so as as
the
numbers uh increase we'll be able to
open that offer
to other people and so that's really um
helpful to have that service in place we
recently
very recently this morning actually
chair heard about there may be an offer
for companies that have over 250 staff
to um provide their own lateral flow
testing
and just waiting for some details on
that and we'll certainly set up a
seminar
for businesses and hopefully next week
if that's the case
to help them in terms of learning from
our experiences
of setting up a site care homes continue
to use
both pcr tests and lateral flow tests
both for staff and residents obviously
those are our most vulnerable residents
and now the pcr tests have been rolled
out to
some supportive living and some home
care staff as well
to make sure that those staff aren't um
are regularly tested the benefits of
asymptomatic testing is that we know
uh following on from our conversation
we've just had is that one in three
people
may um have the virus but not have any
symptoms
and would unknowingly be passing it on
to our vulnerable residents who we are
caring for or um other members of staff
so that's the
emphasis behind asymptomatic testing
um helen will probably update you but
our secondary schools now
are doing lateral flow tests and they
have been tremendous
in uh taking on this program at a very
short time scale
utilizing their existing staff and helen
and her team
are supporting as and when they are
needed
and we still haven't got any information
yet about primary schools
but we do feel it's important that those
primary school teachers
if they want to can attend our lateral
flow testing
site at trafford town hall um
and i think i'll stop there check the
all the other symptomatic sites
the airport the one um on
opposite tescos in stratford uh
partington
and uh trafford park are still up open
up and running we had a slight problem
over christmas where we had some
gritting issues but that's been resolved
um and uh our testing numbers are going
up
uh most people are reporting getting
their test results back from the pcr
tests
within uh 42 to 48 to 72 hours
so that seems to be working remember
last time we had quite a delay in people
getting their results back
um so that area seems to be working okay
so i'll stop their chair
thank you donna uh can i invite helen is
anything you want to add at this stage
before we invite any questions thank you
just really to echo what donna said and
i would say that our secondary schools
have really embraced the challenge of
testing
you know it's been a tricky time for
them but a lot of our schools now
are running with the testing sites one
which is notable
and is a real champion is wellington
school um
and they've been really really good
sharing their expertise
so that's running at the moment so what
that is is staff are tested
twice weekly on the first week that they
come back into school
and then once a week every week going
forward
students are tested twice weekly the
first
week they return again but then only
tested when um
they are identified as a contact from a
case in school and they're tested for
seven days then and that's called test
to release
and we know that there's a couple of
schools in the south um that are running
test release and so far it's been
uh really good i hate to use the word
positive when we talk about testing but
it has been really positive
in terms of our primaries the national
guidance hasn't yet been released about
testing for our primary
schools however like donna said we have
offered the lft testing site
at trafford town hall to our primary
school teaching staff
and that's just just to get them into
the flow of being tested and also that
population health approach in terms of
identifying asymptomatic um
people the testing of students in
primary i think will be
um an area that will take
some significant review but again we're
waiting for national guidance what the
approach will be with that
really our special schools are um
secondary special schools are running
with testing at the moment as well
and our primary special school staff are
also invited to the lft
testing site um in terms of early years
so that's our primary our nurseries our
pvis child minders
we're just surveying them at the moment
to understand their need
and the numbers involved as well and the
offer for the lft
will hopefully go out to them from next
week as well so there's a huge amount of
work that's
happening with testing and um
yeah i would say it's been really
positive in terms of how the settings
have embraced the opportunity to be
tested thanks
uh thank you helen um an observation
really
uh we don't seem to talk about test and
trace anymore
is that just something that we aren't
doing
has it has it has it collapsed as a
system no is it is it working
yes there's test test and trace still
continues i think it's just because
there's been so much activity around
testing wider testing in the community
our um
our teams which is kate myself trisha
and sam we're still
working very hard we've got a number of
outbreak control meetings today
so we deal with the settings that come
through test and trace
our level twos which are the ones the
cases who the national team haven't been
able to contact
still come down to us as our locally
supported contact tracing team
numbers have increased over the last
couple of weeks we're averaging about
45 um cases that our team deal with a
day in terms of
those people who haven't yet been
contacted in terms of settings
at the moment it's predominantly
workplace we do have a number of schools
um uh that we are working with but they
at the moment you know they're managing
it incredibly well um it is that
workplace issue which elena spoke about
previously
that that is um keeping us busy i would
say
thanks that's that's reassuring to hear
i didn't doubt that you weren't
still involved in testing trace at all
uh thanks for that
are there any questions please for
either uh yes i've got
councillor new garage well very briefly
thank you for all that
that hard work on the test and trace i
know it makes a difference
um i just it wasn't a question it's more
a point i am hearing back from people
again
on the national pcr test that tests are
just disappearing there are people that
don't receive a result
or one recently got a positive result
got retested got a negative result got
retested again got a negative result
queried the first positive and was told
i'm sorry we got a
we mixed up and we sent you the wrong
result which is terrible because that
means someone else in the world's
getting a pos is positive but didn't get
a result or
um the the looks like there is again
some sort of strain
on the lighthouse system um not that we
can do much
about it but it needs to be noted
that is existing thank you
thank you uh i don't want to come back
on that at all
um donna may know a bit more we
we tend to hear from places where
they've had confusing results and we
have um we have on occasion been able to
follow up and
um make sure that the right result has
been
has been sorted for people um
again we we occasionally get
notification of lost results but it
hasn't been
it seems it hasn't seemed to be such an
issue
as perhaps it was as earlier on in
um earlier last year um but
as i say we we don't always know we
wouldn't always know
um but we we
i haven't i haven't heard so many i
hadn't heard very many
cases i haven't heard any recently um as
you described
so um but we it it's very difficult for
us to know what
about those because all of that we only
hear about once um
once we get the results through we
wouldn't necessarily know the people
that had a test
and not got a result if they don't get
in touch with us
um donna i don't know if you know
anything if you've heard anything from
any of the um
testing meetings no no we haven't heard
anything um
and um as you said before when when we
did have the delays we we certainly had
a very big inbox so
i'm sorry counselor to hear about those
issues um
if you email us and we can always try
and expedite it nationally
um the problem is is that if there is a
delayed or a missing result
the national system aren't able to
investigate that
until um five days after the test result
but if we could help in any way please
let us know
thank you uh donna for that update um
i've got a raised hand from
shan shannon oh yeah thank you good
morning um
it was a quick question around the
targeted testing
obviously our communities
use the figures that we put out in terms
of benchmarking
the colby and the infection rates i'm
just wondering that obviously
the more we test the the likelihood is
that we'll get a lot more
um positive um results coming back
um but whether out that the way we're
doing our targeted testing is consistent
across gm um
are all the other areas doing their own
thing because my concern is if we've got
a more a better more robust testing
facility what we will see is an increase
in our
figures per 100 thousands which will put
the highlight on those
whereas other districts might lag behind
because their testing is inconsistent or
they're doing it in a slightly different
way
um it's a very good question i think
overall
in terms of the symptomatic testing
shown that's you know the pcr testing
and there is good coverage across the
whole of gm and everyone is following a
very similar model
and in terms of the lateral flow because
they're quite new
um we are having different models in
different areas
i think our colleagues in salford
certainly are using the same model that
we are in terms of targeting key
staffing groups
and other areas are using a mixed model
which we will move on to
in terms of supporting key workforces
and workplaces
in terms of the lateral flow testing um
elerin we were all having a discussion
around this this morning actually sean
about whether
um whether the closeness to a testing
site
geographically if you live closer to a
testing site are you more likely to use
that
and so um i'm sure um some bigger brains
than mine will be working on that data
just to see if there is a correlation
between that but
it's an interesting point you raise
thank you well that's useful
um i think i think we just need to put
some careful comms out then
around the testing so the public
understand the figures a little bit
um because what we want to do is avoid
mass panic but
actually some context to some of those
figures or the increases that that might
come with it
i think i think one of the other things
um i suppose what i'd be saying is if we
are
seeing more cases because more people
are coming forward for testing
well at least we're finding those people
and we're able to deal with it and
people we can encourage people to
self-isolate and we should be able to
get on top of the spread
more easily but the second thing is one
of the um
critical items of data that we do
present and that we always look at
is how many of the people we test are
positive
and so that's that's a key indicator
because as your positivity rate goes up
um then you're more then you have more
if your
numbers are going up and the positivity
rate is going up
and your testing rates are remaining
high you are you you really do start
feeling you've got a bigger problem
whereas if your testing rates go
up but your numbers of people who are
positive don't go up
then you you can be more confident that
you're getting all of the cases
so it is that we don't just look at the
numbers we look at how many of the
report the proportion of people who are
being tested who test positive
and that is a very key indicator for us
and again one that worries us at the
moment because at the moment our
positivity rates
have gone up from um well under 10
percent i think rounds about seven
percent
in parts of december up to sixteen
percent this week
not just well thank you very much chair
thanks for your question shan are there
any further questions at all
can't see any um shall we move on then
to
mass vaccination i'm going to invite
martin pritchard to speak on this city
standing in for rebecca are you today
martin
thank you i am thank you chair so
um apologies if you've heard this before
but what i'll quickly go through is the
the current overall position and then
i'll focus on the
delivery of the vaccines to local people
so as as people know since we last met
there are now
three vaccines that have been approved
for use in the uk
the pfizer vaccine the astrozenica
vaccine and the moderna vaccine
and we are receiving supplies of those
first two into the nhs
it's something else i think is really
important to understand is the way in
which
we are distributing those vaccines to
the population
so something called the jcvi which i
think most of us have become
aware of over the last few weeks the
joint committee for vaccinations in
immunizations have published really
really clear evidence-based guidance
of a number of cohorts of people um
starting off with cohort one which are
those people who live and work
in care homes for the elderly and these
cohorts
are basically uh in levels of risks so
they are the most vulnerable people
to covet and our society and then we
work our way through
down to uh cohort nine which is those
people
aged 50 to 55 and what we are doing
is we are delivering the vaccine to
those cohorts
in sequence of those cohorts because in
doing that we will protect the most
vulnerable
from illness and we will also
start to see in the next few weeks i
hope a reduction on the pressure on
the nhs because by doing that because
they are the most vulnerable
those people are most vulnerable to
being admitted into hospital
and increasing the pressures that we see
at the moment
terms of the delivery mechanisms um
there are there are four different ways
in which
the vaccines are being delivered at the
moment
so hospitals up and down the country are
are delivering vaccines and they are
predominantly focusing on
health and social care staff and it is
both nhs
staff and social care staff and we are
working
locally with manchester foundation trust
to make sure that
social care staff as well as dentists
and pharmacists and opticians are
getting access to those vaccinations
secondly as people will will know about
what i've read about there are the mass
vaccination centers and we have one in
greater manchester that's opened this
week
thirdly there are community pharmacists
and there'll be a network of community
pharmacists
and the first of those open next week
and we have one of those
in in trafford and then finally and
probably most importantly in terms of
the delivery to
the general population we have groups of
gps
in primary care networks and those
groups of gps have come together and are
working together to deliver the vaccine
at the moment to people in cohorts one
which is those people
in elderly care homes and the second
cohort which is those people
aged 80 and above those groups of
gps are in are in waves waves one to
seven
and wave six starts next week and i
think wave seven
is the week after one of the things
that's really really pleasing in
trafford
is our five networks in trafford were
all in waves one to four
and what that has meant is that they all
started delivering the vaccine to local
people
before new year so they are well into
the programme
of delivery for people aged over 80.
as you can imagine behind all of this
with those different ways of delivery so
it's quite a
complex but joined up it program
and from i think tomorrow what we're
promised
is nationally we'll start to see
published the numbers of people that
have been vaccinated
by local authority level so you will be
able to see publicly how many people in
traffic have been vaccinated through
those different routes because of course
some people have been vaccinated the
mass vaccination center most people
through the local gp service
but also some people through nhs trust
and as i say from next week from
pharmacists
absolutely top of the jcvi
cohort list is those people who live or
work in elderly care homes and one of
the things i'm really really pleased to
be able to report to
to this committee is that by the end of
this week
we will have offered vaccinations to all
staff and residents
in in ugly care homes in trafford
and i think that's a really good
achievement because the national aim is
to do that
by the end of january and to get to that
point by the middle of january is a
really good achievement and i think it
reflects the really quick and fast start
that the primary care networks have made
in january so i'm going to stop their
chair because i'm sure people have got
lots of questions
thank you very much martin and before i
do take questions
just some observations from me we are
making really good progress
um i know you briefed the exec uh
earlier
on was it monday this week um about this
um i also think that the messaging that
i've seen sent out by the ccg in
trafford
has been really positive and we also
have now got the vaccination hotline
which i'm sure is it which is really
really good news for people who
because we've had this issue of of the
confusion about
receiving a request from the national
rollout as well as from the gp
and i think we've done an awful lot of
work around that to to reassure
our residents so i will invite questions
who would like to go first
uh councillor new grosh
thank you very much and i've heard that
we are um
50 of the way into our over 80 group
ahead of greater manchester so i've got
to congratulate
everyone on on the efforts have done
this the problem i've got
and this is as a timply ward counsellor
i've had a lot of
calls coming in worried that they aren't
being invited in
and there is a rumor that there's going
to be a vaccination point at lark hill
center i
actually have emails from residents we
turned up
we we saw cues of people at lark hill
yesterday
maybe some signage so rumors running
unfortunately
and maybe we could have some clarity on
on
on perhaps if if certain areas might be
behind
others uh what what's being done to to
bring up everybody to a good level
thank you thank you so to answer that
question in two parts uh lark hill
refers to the community pharmacy service
that um that is starting next week so
that's what the lark hill
site is it's the community pharmacy
service and
what we're doing is the the primary care
networks
are working to provide mutual aid across
the different networks
so if one network has got you know made
great
substantial progress in terms of the
over eighties and another network hasn't
what they're doing is supporting each
other both with uh transferring
vaccines across the sides and also in
terms of people to do that
so that's why that's the way we're
managing it across the different
networks
because as you can imagine at the moment
um that the supply chain is absolutely
working itself out
and there are inevitably some issues in
that but the mutual aid between between
the networks has been absolutely first
class in terms of trying to manage that
thank you um i've now got i've got two
waiting i'll take cancer act and then
counsel accordingly
yeah thanks chad um it's just really
uh to to ask which vaccine are we using
um is it the fight for one or is it the
um the zenica one
and um and if it is
the first one um how is it being stored
and
is there any logistical problems that
you
you you're encountering counting
well thank you for that question because
it allows me to provide all kinds of
technical information about freezers and
fridges and
and all of that kind of good stuff so
the short answer is um we're getting
both the pfizer and the astrazeneca
vaccine into trafford and the reason why
this has been set up in terms of groups
of practices working together because as
you as you hinted in the question
the fisa vaccine requires particular
storage at particular temperatures
and to do that required particular
equipment and and all of those things
and that's why at this stage we've got
groups of practices to work together
and delivery out of a small number of
sites rather than all of the different
practices which you get with a with a
flu
program um the the astrazeneca vaccine
the storage requirements are different
it is much more like a flu vaccine in
terms of stored at kind of normal fridge
temperatures but i hasten to add not in
normal uh fridges
so we're getting both of those vaccines
at the moment and we are
basically using every single vaccine we
can get to
vaccinate people what we are doing is
we're we're using the astrazeneca
vaccine particularly in the vaccination
of people who are in care homes
because it is easier to transport
because we don't have those issues a
particular cold storage
and it has a much longer shelf life so
we are using those vaccines
intelligently
against those initial cohorts um
somebody asked me earlier in the week
and it may be we get to a point you know
later in the year or
or next year or whenever where you know
there may be a choice of vaccine
but at the moment um you know we do have
a supply we do need to get out as
quickly as possible so we're just using
both vaccines intelligently giving those
storage requirements
can i just have a follow-up question
which is
the second vaccine that people will have
um obviously that
would there be any problems in terms of
getting mixed up of which ones they've
had in the first place
and how are you actually managing you
know who gets those second
ones um and you know the
the time lapse in in between so
it'd be useful just to have an
explanation around that
the information goes back basically into
people's care records so you know when
you
sit in front of your gp and your gp's
typing away at the computer
your gp's typing into your care record
and that's where the information will be
stored about which vaccine you had
and when you had that vaccine that
allows us to automate the recall process
if that makes sense
um so when people go for their second
vaccine what the vaccinator
will will be able to see is uh to make
sure
they know which which type of vaccine
you have first time around
so you get the second vaccine of the of
the same kind in that
it is always a doctor who will record
that regardless of where you've been
being tested it's not it's not
necessarily a doctor who will record
that but it be a trained vaccinator who
will record that information
and to get extremely technical with you
at the moment it goes into something
called the pinnacle system and the
pinnacle system then links to the gp
record
and puts that information into the gp
record
okay thanks councillor can i invite khan
with your question please
yeah i'm i'm hearing quite a lot of
traffic on the uh social media which is
actually saying that many
pensioners in greater manchester are
being told to
travel as far as telford or birmingham
to get vaccinations i'm not
sure where this is coming from but is
there any truth in this kind of a
story so i i've i've heard the same
thing and having investigated it over
the weekend
my understanding is that if somebody
gets a letter because at the moment we
just want to get as many vaccines out to
people as possible in those
in those particular cohorts so those
people who haven't
had their vaccines from the gp may well
receive a letter inviting them to go to
one of the math testing centers and
obviously our local one is at the etihad
tennis center
in the city of manchester when you log
on to
the site i think what happens is you you
can actually see
all of the vaccination centers within
100 miles of your home
and that includes i think the birmingham
um
center so people are seeing the
birmingham center
in that and i think uh it can lead to
some confusion that they think they've
been invited to the birmingham center
it's a bit like the testing system and
and helen
um and laura and eleanor and donna and
others on the call will recognize it
from the testing system that when you
log on to the testing system
because it's a national booking system
you see you know
all of the testing centers that are
around so
my message would be to people that um if
you can travel to
the etihad center then you know please
feel free to book
on that but you will be contacted by
your local gp service and be offered
to a more local vaccination but if you
can get a vaccination the etihad centre
you can travel there you can make
arrangements
then i would encourage people to do so
because the quicker we get our older
people vaccinated
the better
thank you martin um council accordingly
did you have a question
yeah yes thanks chair um
in terms of care homes um um
and over 80s we've talked about offering
the vaccine
and i'm just picking up on on that i'm
trying to understand
how many people are not taking up the
offer because it
is crucial particularly in care homes
where you've got a closed environment
so um it's really understanding
are is there a small cadre of people
that are refusing that even in care
homes
and is that going to cause problems in
future
so it is an offer you can't make anybody
have the vaccine against their will but
what we're seeing is incredibly strong
uptake across the whole population that
we're being offered this
so uh in in care homes you know the
the anecdotal evidence that i've got
from people from everybody involved in
that
is you know people really are wanting
this vaccine but there will be some
people for whatever reason that decide
not to take it up and what we need to
understand is
um what are the reasons uh behind that
and what do we do about it so at the
moment when we start to see the data in
the next day or so
then i think it will enable us to really
understand if there is an issue
and what we need to do around this issue
the the previous uh counselor mentioned
there are all kinds of things on social
media
and we all need to work together to
combat some of the you know frankly
unhelpful messages that are out there on
social media
can i just come back on that just a very
quick one
in some ways you don't need to answer
this now but um
it's it's perhaps one for the next month
but
i mean the the the efficiency of the
virus
is not 100 uh
that's been recognized all the way
through and particularly on one dose of
the
virus it's not 100 so
in the next month uh we are likely to
get
by by just statistically
true we are going to get people for whom
the virus fails
and that's going to be a pr issue it's
not happened yet it couldn't happen yet
because
they've not had the virus long enough
but i think it's one for the future
that uh that was a set of questions that
eleanor is far more
qualified to answer than i am i think i
think
i'd like to say a couple of things
though one is that what we make is very
clear which is the effectiveness of the
vaccine
um comes in two to three weeks after the
vaccine has been
administered so you don't get instant
protection from the vaccine
and with all vaccine programs the
protection is at a public health level
not always necessarily an individual
level so social distancing
uh good infect infection prevention and
control
remain absolutely paramount through this
and one of the things i'm doing is
working with our
mass testing expert group that we've got
in greater manchester to get some really
clear messages
to health and social care staff about
the importance of maintaining rigorous
infection
prevention and control and all the other
measures
beyond having the vaccination programme
and
donna is nodding at me stagely so she
may want to add to that
i think it's such a good point martin
and it's probably a point that i was
going to make around testing is that
testing isn't the golden nugget it
doesn't give you your you know
you're free to do whatever you can the
the the focus on
um respiratory hygiene on hand washing
on social distances is just so important
so i'm really pleased to hear about that
work happening at gm
and and just to add to that it is that
no vaccine is 100
effective and as martin says um we do
rely on people being vaccinated to
reduce the risk and it does reduce the
risk to themselves and particularly
these vaccines have been designed
to reduce the risk of serious illness
and hospitalization
so some people may get covid still but
hopefully
they will get a more if they do get it
it will be milder than it would have
otherwise been
the other thing is with these vaccines
is that they have very much been
designed as i say to reduce the risk of
hospitalization and of death
and we don't know yet how much they
reduce
transmission so some vaccines work
well to both suppress your infectious
the symptoms that you would experience
and how infectious you might be to other
people this vaccine has been designed to
reduce the hospitalization and the
serious consequences
we hope that it will also reduce
transmission because
hopefully if you have fewer symptoms you
will also
be less infectious but we don't know
that yet so
it's there's two things to stress to
people with fact with the vaccination
one is as martin says it takes
a couple of weeks for your body to start
producing
the the antibodies to the vaccine so
that it actually works
so you absolutely must wait those two or
three weeks before you do anything
different
at all the second is it it should
provide protection to you but it may not
stop you if you were exposed to it
giving it to somebody else so it really
is important
to get our population rates of covet
down
and testing is one way of by identifying
people
but the testing only works for people
are then prepared to
self-isolate afterwards the vaccination
will only work if people also
really make sure that they don't put
themselves at any additional risk even
if they have been vaccinated
so they're all really important parts
but a lot of it still comes down to
what is i'm afraid um rather depressing
messages for many people about
we have to continue with the other steps
as well certainly through the winter
thanks for the clarity there um eleanor
and martin because
there was a big feature this morning on
on times radio about
the vaccine and it is the vaccine's
designed to stop you getting seriously
ill
and indeed it has been reported that
there is an a e nurse somewhere
in the south who has had the vaccine uh
one dose of the vaccine
and has since uh tested positive for
covid
and so it's not guaranteed that you know
as you say but it stops you getting
seriously and that's the key message uh
i've got a
question from councillor welton and then
i've got a question from uh
dorothy evans thank you chair
uh just um an example of the kind of
dilemma that residents are going through
at the moment um
so a resident whose mother was invited
to um have an appointment at altering
him for the vaccine at
altrinham health hub but when they came
to make an appointment they were told
that there was
there were no more slots i think no more
i don't think there was
you know i think problems with the
vaccine supply maybe
um you know an interruption in the
vaccine supply um so they then got
appointments they then got appointments
on the national scheme at
i think offers of appointments at
macclesfield and um
and at manchester city as well
but the um the mother doesn't drive
you know she's advanced years and so
they now have the dilemma do they
put her in a car get in a car with her
take her to the vaccine
center and get the vaccine or is that
regarded as too much of a risk
you know should they just wait until
until the austrian health hub
at some point is vaccinating people
again and has more slots
thank you
in answer to that it's really difficult
i know it's really difficult i think
i know i certainly do i've got family
members who've phoning me up on a
regular basis saying when will i get my
vaccine when will i get my vaccine
um the ultragum health alliance was a
first wave site they started
the absolute first of the delivery of
this they are
absolutely working their way through all
of the people
aged over 80 and the practices are
supported on that
so if if that particular person didn't
take up
the manchester city site or the other
site the ultimate health alliance will
be in touch with them to get them a slot
and get them in there
thank you martin and dorothy you've got
a question
yeah i've got a question and some
information the first is
do people have a choice as to which
vaccine
they receive given the publication about
both vaccines
the short answer to that is unless there
is a medical reason why they can
only have one of the vaccines or the
other of the vaccine
then at this point then no because we
have more people who need vaccination
than we have
vaccines for okay this the second point
is that certainly within our community
there is um potentially a reluctance to
take up the vaccine
so there is going to be on saturday
the 16th of january between 11 o'clock
and 11 30 what we're calling a health
hour
and that health hour is going to feature
um
a panel of consultants and senior health
people within the within the nhs who
have had the vaccine
and are going to be available to answer
any concerns
now these these will all be people um
consultants and
senior professionals from the nhs
and therefore if anybody wants to join
in that panel discussion if you can
take my details i will ensure that i
pass
the information on to anybody that is
interested i think it's so important
and particularly when we've got people
within the nhs who are taking up the
vaccine
and providing positive messages about
the uptake
thank you for that it's a really
important issue to make sure
we get uptake across all of our
communities
for the vaccine again ellen that's your
area of expertise what we see in the
past only is different levels of uptake
to
vaccination programs
we do we do and i think one of the key
things i want to be
really stressing with people for this
vaccine
particularly as it is designed to reduce
hospitalization
and mortality and death and the deaths
is that we really really do need to get
the rates
absolutely as high as we can in our most
vulnerable people
so that's our people with our with um
chronic
serious underlying conditions and in our
over 80s and our over 75s
over 70 population because they're the
people who are most likely to be
seriously ill from this
this disease and they're the people for
whom the vaccine is most likely to have
the biggest impact
and as martin said i think um it's
between 80 and 80 percent of
um 80 and 85 percent of the deaths have
been in the
top four categories of people so far in
the uk and in the pandemic
so the only way we will get those death
rates effectively down
is if we manage to get really good
uptake in our over 80s and
in our populations with chronic
underlying conditions
and we know that um well actually we've
got two different things going on there
our more affluent population are more
likely to live to be over 80
but we need to so we need to make sure
so that's um one that's one of the
inequalities that's going in the other
direction and actually
um that popul our older people tend to
be
very um you do tend to certainly we see
this with flu that people are
are keen to have that vaccination but we
still see variation
and are more deprived older people
living in more
deprived populations tend for all sorts
of reasons to be less likely to
have get a good uptake in in that for
flu vaccination
and we are concerned to make sure that
that doesn't happen again in
um with covid because what we don't want
to see is the
existing inequalities that we're already
seeing in the death rates
from kovid being exacerbated by some
groups
for all sorts of reasons not accepting
the vaccination
and the same is true for people with
chronic
and serious underlying conditions again
with flu vaccine where people with
chronic conditions
are eligible to be vaccinated we never
get
in traffic i don't think we've ever got
to the rate of vaccination the target
rate of vaccination
and again we see quite strong
inequalities gradients in the uptake of
that
so for me um absolutely before we start
thinking about who else is vaccinated
and how do we move on from those first
four co
first forward groups of people that
martin has described
i really want us to be absolutely
confident that we have got
the jabs into the arms all of the people
who are in those highest risk groups
because that's the only way we're going
to make a real difference to the death
rates
and i think everything any of us can do
to try and encourage people
and i absolutely understand you know
with the new vaccine people can be
hesitant about it but with we've put you
know there's been a lot of trials the
studies are really good i have complete
faith
in the jcvi and their guidance and and
the
regulators on this these are not
political positions these are scientists
um so i would strongly encourage
everybody to take the vaccine as soon as
they're um offered it and if you have
family members who are hesitant
you know please please do try and talk
to them and encourage them to take that
vaccine as soon as possible
because we do not want to see further
deaths
in some of our most vulnerable groups if
we could present
prevent that and that's my biggest
concern at the moment
to make sure we don't have inequalities
and vaccination
thank you for all the contributions
under under mass vaccination shall we
move on
to um updated escalations from the kovid
19
engagement coordination group nigel
hi thank you council freeman uh just a
few updates
from me um i mentioned at the last
meeting uh we were a newly formed
engagement team at that time
uh and we've been put together to
strengthen and build on the existing
community engaged work that's been going
on around covered and to ensure some
better coordination so
um we're putting that team together we
have two uh local neighborhood leads in
place already and we are going to uh
be interviewing the next couple of days
for the other two lead posts so
hopefully with the next
you know a couple of weeks we'll have
more capacity to build on the work that
we're doing
so that's a real positive uh i also
mentioned at the last fourth meeting
the community champion scheme
uh if you remember this is a scheme
that's been launched by the ministry of
housing communities local government and
they were looking for us to put forward
a bid
for funding to uh to support people
showing to be most at risk of covert 19
including in our ethnic minority groups
um
so we put that bid in in december we've
had some initial
uh feedback on a gm basis uh it's
looking
really positive that we'll get most of
the funding that we've asked for uh both
that hasn't been confirmed yet and
that's waiting for ministerial sign off
so hopefully we'll get
get some news on that within the next
week or so and if we do we can then
uh move on with the work that we want to
do which is going to be
centered around recruiting a network of
community champions to engage with our
most vulnerable groups
in trafford so that that could be really
positive um
we have in terms of the events there's
just one event that i wanted to mention
that we did before christmas that was on
christmas eve that we did with
um the cabinet offices community street
team
so they had a so a group of people that
we worked with
and we did some visits around old
trafford and stratford and the aim of
this was to talk to the public
about the restrictions and rules are in
place and the kind of key covered
messaging
and to get some insight into people feel
about the messaging so
we're just waiting to hear back from the
cabinet office around the findings of
that but again once we get that we can
share that
with you at the next next meeting um
we've also been um in terms of
uh volunteers we've been helping with
colleagues at thrive at ccg
to help coordinate getting volunteers
at the vaccination clinics which uh the
ones that martin mentioned around the
primary care networks that gp practices
so
we're able to help match up the
volunteers with the different practices
to make sure they were there to support
the support with the vaccine roll out um
we've also had in the last few days some
really really good meetings with some
key contacts within the
bame community which um
we've got some additional further
contacts to follow up on and some good
sort of volunteers that are looking to
help us really take forward
the work that we want to do around
getting some really good messaging out
to that community so we're gonna
be working with our comms colleagues um
both at the council and the ccg to make
sure we've got a really good
uh joined up approach on this and try
and combat some of the
the messaging that has been out there on
on social media
and uh finally the last thing i wanted
to mention was around
the work that our comms colleagues have
also been ensuring that our
website and social media has been uh
updated as you would expect to reflect
the latest lockdown restrictions
and continuing to kind of get the
messaging out so push that kind of stay
at home message
and ensure and encourage that everyone
plays their part
in uh following the guidance so that was
it for me cancer free
thank you uh oh santa you've got a
question to ask shannon
sorry mike it it it was um the end was
raised a bit early but if i can
still um ask the questions i'll be
grateful
i i was just wondering are you going to
come in on the next one under the s
enforcement group is that is it relating
to that sean
it isn't it isn't uh um if you will the
question is
um i think there's a certain amount of
anxiety about amongst
um i'm a doctor that i've heard about
the elderly that
they might get missed out around the
vaccination it's just
how how are we ensuring that people uh
what method we're using to
get that information across and it links
into some of the crime prevention stuff
is it
is it going to be a letter that they
receive or something another web way
mold of contact so people aren't
targeted by unscrupulous and i think
there's a few scams going around
uh thanks i think my understanding and
uh if martin's still with us they will
receive a letter from their their gp is
that correct
eleanor
that they're commuting
so yes um people should i should get a
lesson from their gp's inviting them
um and or from the or they'll be able to
book on themselves onto the
national system so nobody should be
being approached by anyone
who is not a healthcare professional
offering um vaccination
there has been i mean there's been a
terrible case wasn't there of someone
who was um a scam of someone going
around but
um i mean absolutely i think i think one
of the messages we have been trying to
make sure is getting out that
this this is a you know the supplies of
this vaccine are absolutely limited to
nhs settings
um and if anyone is offering you
anything that has not
come from your gp or a known trusted
health
professional um it's not the real
vaccine it absolutely is not
there is there is no alternative route
for vaccination
that's that's really useful and chair
thank you and we'll reinforce some of
those messages through our own
social media thank you
sean uh councilloracton yeah it
it might not be for nigel i don't know
but um
it's about homeless people um you know
how how are we dealing with homeless
people because obviously
um they are um
you know it's a difficult group isn't it
to
to to sort of get messages across too
and and i know that
uh it's seen as you know
a priority in in terms of spreading the
disease as well
if if you're homeless and wandering the
streets and
and so on i know we don't have you know
a
huge number of homelessness uh
as in manchester and so on but um
it could be an issue so yeah certainly
on the homeless population most of the
homeless people
there isn't at the moment homeless
people per se
are not in the top four crop priority
groups however a number of homeless
people
will have um very serious underlying
health conditions and so would actually
be caught in that group so not because
of being homeless but because of their
health conditions
so um but homeless people are a group
that are very much
being being looked at as how we how we
support them effectively
um i mean it's how we track them as well
you know to ensure that they do get that
opportunity
absolutely and manchester have been
doing i mean we have very few
in trafford we have very few people who
are living on the streets very very few
but obviously we have a lot more people
in precarious accommodation
but manchester have been lead where they
have a much more significant issue with
people living on
on the streets um they have been leading
on the piece of work about how to
best protect homeless people through
through the whole of covid
and we work closely with them thank you
thank you council um i don't see any
further questions at this point so can
we move on to the um
updated escalations from the kobe 19
enforcement group
helen and shan hi thanks councillor
freeman
and sean might want to come in on this
as well
um so the council received um
less complaints around kind of
residential breaches over christmas but
that's because we closed down over
christmas and i think it's fair to
say that gmp have very much received the
lion's share
of those cases we've updated our
processes
and since we've come back to reflect the
the new stay at home measures
and we work through um all the reports
that come to us and the list that goes
to gmp as well just to make sure that
none are slipping through the cracks and
that we're not having a situation where
the council the police and housing are
going to one property and then nobody's
going to the other so
we make sure that they all get responded
to and
we hold the enforcement group every
monday
so meeting was held on monday afternoon
which is is well attended by different
partners
i think the main things that have come
out of that is obviously
there's less that people can do at the
moment so if the weather is nice
people want to go out and walk which is
it's fair enough
and but then we've got some locations
where there are businesses such as
takeaways you can
operate under the regulations but if you
have a lot of people turning up or
wanting to buy a cappuccino and
congregate
outside that can be quite difficult for
the businesses to manage
and then you've got issues around social
distancing and so there's some joint
work going on between
environmental health and our greater
manchester police
and neighborhood teams around that
and i think eleanor touched on this
before as well
is that we believe that there are still
people who are
going into work for example in offices
and where they are able to work from
home but perhaps employers are still
expecting people to to go into the
office and the regulations does kind of
state that you should be
um working from home unless you
reasonably cannot possibly kind of
work from home you shouldn't be going
into the office so we need to bolster
some communications around that as well
so
we do have a representative from our
communications team
that attends the enforcement meeting on
a monday so there's some some work
around that
and and then i think sean has touched on
this as well was around the
um post that went round uh social media
and i think was in the news as well
around scams
and vaccinations and gmp have done some
comms around that so i think it's
getting that message out to people as
well particularly in our vulnerable
communities that you know anybody who's
approaching you other than
the nhs or a care worker will not be
genuinely offering a vaccination and it
will be a scam such as making sure that
people are aware of that who may not
necessarily have access to social media
and seeing those posts
that was just a quick kind of fly
through from me i think sean i don't
know whether you've got
more that you want to to add to that
yeah
thanks ellen um i mean i think cheerful
morris it's really important that
we get the right balance in terms of
policing in trafford
and and that's exactly what we we've
been striving for and
i think the challenge we've got is
reality versus perception
i think some of the stuff that we see on
social media is really not helpful in
terms of
what sometimes uh how it influences
around the public's opinion around what
we're doing
in reality we're being real
proportionate in terms of the reports
we're using the four e's we're adopting
that method
and we will issue fines and we will take
action but
particularly against those that are
repeating that behavior
or not listening to advice but what we
won't be doing
is being overzealous in our powers and i
think that's really important message to
get out uh we're there
with the supporting legislation but we
do it in a proportionate manner
um because it's really important that we
keep keep the public inside to keep that
confidence going
and i think in trafford um certainly
from a policing perspective what we are
seeing
um yeah the roads are busier and there's
a lot more people
uh knocking about but in reality we're
seeing less reports from people
um reporting breaches um
and on the whole the compliance to
covered
um is there it's just the small minority
that are spoiling it
and just to touch on some of our beauty
spots are really busy um we're asking
people to stay local and i'm not getting
drawn into that
conversation what is local what isn't
but what we find in some of the beauty
sports people are converging in mass
and there's absolutely no issue with
that because we're encouraging people to
take exercise
and stay local so it stands to reason
that these areas will get busy
but just to reinforce some of the
messages that have been put out during
this meeting it's about that
keeping that distance keeping the
hygiene the mass wearing wherever
possible
and the messaging that's been going out
by the local authorities around
treating yourself as if you have got
colvid and using that as a bit of a
barometer in terms of
how you behave when you're outside but
there's no real issues i think it feels
very different to the initial lockdown
for many of the reasons that i've
already mentioned
uh but we will continue to police in a
proportionate manner
um and i'd be really interested to hear
if the communities are we've got
local members that are feeling that the
the policing is overzealous so we can
sort of learn from that but
that's certainly not my my view at this
moment in time
uh thank you sean thanks for that
reassurance i'm just wondering uh
perhaps nigel can answer this have we
received the letter from the home
secretary yet reminding local
authorities
uh of our enforcement powers that she
talked about on the tv last night as if
we
really need to be reminded that is uh if
we do i'd like to see a copy of that um
any questions at all for either helen or
um
or shan
thank you uh just before i move on then
i just would like to say that
shannon i do know that uh it's a
difficult time for the police at the
moment
and perhaps more so in greater
manchester than other forces
because of some of the publicity you've
had but i'd like to set on record our
thanks
to the work of your your officers
offices and
and the the way that you are policing
this um because
the very fact that uh you know i i've
certainly not
not heard any poor publicity
about the actions of trafford police i
just want you to know that you continue
to enjoy our full support thank you for
the work that you're doing
thanks chair really appreciated uh can
we move on then to the update from the
age well board
from louise please thank you councillor
freeman just a very brief one from me
and we've had a couple of um people
who've come forward to
um the old people's voices which is
great over the christmas period so we're
following up with them
and i think that really links well to
nigel's point around the community
champions that you know there are people
out there in our community who want to
get involved and be a voice for the
community
um and then uh some of the age world
book clubs were being passed out
i know at the vaccine clinics and there
is still a supply of
a small supply of them available so if
anybody
does want to pick up any of those
they're being held at the
age uk hq in ernst at the moment
so thank you chair just a brief one from
me
thank you louise any questions at all
around that
i don't see any so we then move on to
the public engagement board activity or
board members is there anything general
anybody wants to raise at all
is there anything i just made the
observation about
is is it appropriate that we talk about
messaging at all i don't
any differences that we want to make to
it going forward
or we've picked up i think we've picked
up an awful lot from today's meeting
around the sort of messaging i'm just
wondering as well whether
we really need to whether we do want to
go ahead and get some videos
uh recorded by um by both
jane slater and joe harding to go out
which we discussed before christmas
yes am i yeah
yes please um i think more videos and
more videos from um
other board members as well please and
making sure that we've got messages on
everybody's websites
i think the main message i would be
wanting to get out from today is
that um there are so many
we've got lots compared to where we were
in march
there's so much more we can do we
understand so much more about covid
as as shan was saying most people are
really compliant
we're in a difficult position at the
moment because it's winter
viruses spread more easily and winter
people are indoors more more in winter
um we do need to be just but it is that
message about actually
we're we're on the way to beating this
it is still a long slog and it's just
making sure that we keep going over the
winter
to really adjust our behaviors continue
to really think about what we're doing
and why we're doing it
reducing those contacts but at the same
time picking up that point about you
know actually our physical and mental
health
are really important so keeping that
exercise going
will will do your physical and your
mental health good but
please don't go anywhere where there's
crowds of people
um you know get to know your local area
and it's amazing what you find in your
local area just
walking around two and three miles
routes around your local area
all the different cut-throughs and
gino's and so on really interesting
stuff i think lots of people have found
about their local areas so
focus on that thank you
eleanor i've got to council accordingly
signed up
um yeah it's just really for the future
um i'm optimistic over the vaccine and
i'm optimistic that you'll have
quite a quick impact on hospitalizations
and things like that
at that point i become worried because
the message will go out
that it's over and we will struggle
i i i i almost imagine it will get
harder to recruit people for vaccination
as we work through the tears simply
because the hospitalizations will be
down by that
point we would hope and if they're not
then the vaccine is not working
really um so i think the messaging will
have to change
uh over the coming weeks a little bit
and it'll be about remain
maintaining vigilance rather than um
increasing it that's right thanks mike
and councillor new grosh well just very
briefly is it
who is it i can request a couple of
signs for lark hill to explain what's
about to happen to just
calm some people down because if i'm
getting cues there or groups there
yesterday there's five more days to go
before that becomes
an active center and what comes
is it possible to put out for that um
some advice on on when and what to put
out just
because i know there's a pent-up demand
in my area
thank you
you're on mute it's not it's not liking
me i'm clicking the mute
um i think for the signage um it depends
who um it's probably all of these
questions are best
um directed through to rebecca domain
and martin pritchard at the ccg
depending who owns the building and so
on um and i don't know who
who deals with signage within the
council nigel you i'm sure you know
who who people can be directed to if
there's a need for any street signage on
non
on council land um but it may be that
it's a signage that's needed for an nhs
building
in which case um rebecca i'm sure we'll
be able to to assist
and we can pick this up ellie um who's
on the call and
she will be working with the closely
with the ccg around messaging so i'm
sure that um
we'll be thinking about how some tweets
that we can put out
and the gps have been fantastic as well
about sending out text messages to
people
so we can pick this up with um ellie and
i will pick this up outside the meeting
with jamie oliver and the
the comms teams to make sure that we get
those messages out to people
and absolutely copy in counsellors
because
we know that uh you're a fantastic
source of
information sharing so we'd be very
grateful if you could
um we'll get you messages for you to
send
thank you thank you for that and i'll
speak with both joe harding
and jane slater about them talking to
various people in adult
and and with yourselves about creating
some videos to get out on social media
um there is one item of any of the
business
that's for to inform members of the
board that the health scrutiny committee
has resumed its work and the first
meeting will take place
on thursday the 28th of january at 6 30
pm
um where members of the public and
community groups invited to take part in
the meeting
and submit public questions amongst the
items on the agenda will be how to
replicate the success of community hubs
the access to primary care and domestic
abuse
and if so i just wanted to bring that to
the attention of this board that
the health scrutiny committee is
resuming its work later this month
is there any other items of any other
business
well i think that therefore concludes
the business i think we've got through
quite well today in an hour and a half
because we really have discussed uh
quite a lot today got through a lot can
i kind of
thank you all for your continued work um
and your resilience
in dealing with what is extremely
difficult situation
in traffic at the moment and and right
across gm
and we meet again in a fortnight's time
thank you very much for your attendance
today